now I for one would like to see Justice
be served to the person
who stole her from us in this very
tragic violent and criminal way
that was one of Dr Gwen M's ralla's
fellow classmates speaking out about her
tragic death over the weekend police say
she was stabbed to death by her husband
who then turned the knife on himself
before calling police and police
arresting a 33-year-old man for a murder
charge we do thank you for joining us
here at five o'clock I'm Denise Valdez
and I'm Brian Loftis eight news now
reporter Brian will spoke to her fellow
classmates today tells us how the
community is doing
emotional day here at the Kirk accordion
school of medicine as friends colleagues
and fellow doctors remember Dr Gwen M
zerala she was a brilliant young woman
friend daughter
physician
with a kind heart Community still in
shock as amsarala's colleagues spoke
about the recent loss of their friend
one of them expressing their anger Gwen
deserved better than this Dr Michael
dicaria also worked alongside amzarala
and said she wanted to be a pulmonary
critical care physician she was witty
she was fun
and she was she'll truly be missed by
Everyone by everyone who knew her it's a
pain her family and friends are still
trying to comprehend for Dr Omar it
still doesn't seem real every day I
would wake up and hope that the reality
wasn't true
um until eventually it sank in many
showing love and support through the
GoFundMe page though donations already
exceeding the amount to put her to rest
and she will be sorely missed
not only by her colleagues and her loved
ones but also by the thousands of
patients that she would have treated
over the course of her career a legacy
that her friends and colleagues say will
live on forever reporting in the Medical
District Brian will 8 News Now
now if you or someone you know needs
help please remember you can call The
Crisis Support Services of Nevada there
is the hotline number
775-221-7600 you can also text s-a-s-s
to
839-863 or call 988 for immediate help